the chapel of anticipation the place
where we begin our long mysterious
Journey throughout the lands between but
have you ever thought to yourself why
did we start here were we transported
here did we simply just wake up inside
this church it's hard to say exactly but
this area which you can't access unless
you started a new character or used the
way gate at the four belfries brings up
a lot of questions I feel like this
starting area is a very under discussed
in the Elder ring community so I'd like
to go over it with you today make sure
to subscribe all that good YouTube stuff
it helps a lot also we've got a Discord
full of a lot of cool people join up if
you want to and I'm trying to be more
active on Twitter as well with all that
said let's talk about the chapel of
anticipation
for the longest time I always thought
this was the Church of anticipation but
it's actually a chapel the difference
between the two is that a chapel is
usually just a single small room to
Worship in and can be anywhere usually
attached to places that have nothing to
do with religion all we can find at
first in this small Chapel is a dead
Maiden who was likely supposed to greet
us here upon our arrival however it
looks like someone wanted us to be
maidenless instead the person who killed
our Maiden is most likely Vare who has
already covered in blood and knows more
about our maidenless situation than we
do at this point oh yes
tarnished are we come to the lands
between for the Elden ring
of course you have no shame in it
unfortunately for you however you are
maidenless but along with the question
of how we started the game in the chapel
of anticipation how did we end up this
far down to the south in the stranded
graveyard after we either died to the
Scion or fell to our death after
defeating it well either way obviously
we do die but after our defeat to the
Scion it likely threw us into the ocean
below for our body to be lost at sea
just like if we fall to our death as
well but instead our body likely washed
up on the shore of one of the nearby
beaches someone likely saw our worthless
tarnish body and threw it down into the
stranded graveyard if we take a closer
look around this area we definitely
aren't the first to be thrown down here
however our situation is different we've
been given the guy guidance of Grace and
no matter how many times we die we will
come back to life by Grace if you didn't
know this is the reason we respawn after
each death we have a purpose so the
guidance of Grace won't let us die every
from software game has a detailed lore
reason for the player coming back to
life over and over again it makes it
that much more immersive and special
it's very cool and one of the biggest
reasons I got into lore with all the
from software games but getting back to
the Chapel of anticipation this is
likely just one of the many different
places the tarnished who have been given
Grace come back to the lands between if
I had to guess our dead body was likely
placed here by the maiden who is also
meant to greet us when our soul returns
to our body when our Grace is restored
but thanks to Vare we don't really get
that luxury there is another dead Maiden
that we can find at the church of
inhibition inhibition to those who don't
know is defined as a feeling that may
makes one self-conscious and unable to
act in a natural way like being shy
reserved or some kind of mental block
this could mean many different things
inside a church with a statue of Queen
America maybe this is where people
prayed to release their inner
inhibitions so they could fully serve
and believe in the golden order or it
could be the exact opposite and is a
church dedicated to the inhibitions that
Queen America now has for the golden
order what we can find here are the
clothes of a finger Maiden the same
clothes as the dead Maiden inside the
chapel of anticipation the description
reads as the maidens live to serve a
chosen tarnished the guidance of Grace
would ensure that the pair would be
brought together or at least such was
the promise long ago as we know we are
one of these chosen tarnished once we
are invited by Melina to the Roundtable
hold we find that we are not the only
tarnished to return to the lands between
however we have one major ability that
no other tarnished has the ability to
see the guidance of Grace by the way
you still see it
the guidance of Grace you do
wonderful news most tarnished are blind
to it these days you are something of a
rare breed
so this essentially confirms to us that
we are somewhat different from the other
tarnished in the round table hold who
according to vary are unexceptional
people before the round table was chock
full of venerated Warriors but now it's
home to Puff chests and has beans I fear
you've been terribly disappointed so it
seems to me that Vare is trying to
manipulate us through his dialogue and
somewhat obvious murder of our Maiden he
is trying to pull us in a different
direction to join moog's new Dynasty I
definitely want to explore vari's
intentions with us in another video but
for now I think Vari killing our Maiden
in the chapel of anticipation was just
an example of the many characters
throughout the game who try to alter a
tarnished path if we really think about
it most of the other tarnish we meet are
easily susceptible to manipulation and
can be altered from their true path porn
and the gold mass roderica and her
spirit summons dialos with the volcano
Manor and the jars of jarberg D with
weeding out death root FIA with Godwin
nepheli Liu working with Gideon a couple
of the tarnish just seem to be too far
gone Roger investigating way too deep
underneath Stormville castle and his
body starts to succumb to the spread of
death root and the dung eater who was
likely always this batshit insane what
I'm getting at is that everybody who
isn't tarnished seems to try and take
advantage of the tarnished excluding
Gideon who is a tarnished and I still
believe is the major villain in this
entire story made a couple videos about
it you should go watch it if you haven't
already but the tarnish path seems to be
obvious to everyone except for us varai
knew exactly where we'd start our
journey to kill our maiden and where our
body would be thrown into while knowing
or at least hoping we'd come back to
life and pursue the Elden ring he
literally meets us as soon as we open
the door and step out to the first step
side of Grace our journey to the Elden
ring must be such a strenuous Journey
that most tarnished bail and give up
people who are not tarnished know this
as well and have seen the tarnished fail
so many times at this point that they
know they can easily alter their path
with a little work and manipulation I
believe the reason we start in the
chapel of anticipation is because it's
just one of the few places a tarnished
who has received their Grace returns to
to start their Journey Through the lands
between the other key items we can find
in this area are two Ash summons storm
Park den and the storm Hawk King which
both offer connections to Stormville
Castle which was likely connected to
this Chapel at one point in time
thornvale either purposely cut off its
connection to the chapel or it was just
by natural causes maybe the high wind
storms that are constantly swirling
through this area stormvale even had a
grafted Scion guard the chapel as well
just in case a tarnish does come back to
the lands between and it can be taken
care of but where did we come from we
had to Journey from somewhere to return
to our home across the fog to the lands
between right well to me I believe our
spirit was returned to our body from the
ergary itself this isn't a hundred
percent but the opening cut scene where
the narrator mentions us a tarnished of
no Renown who was also chosen to return
the surrounding area around our
character here reminds me a lot of the
inner area of the urge tree where we can
find Queen America and fight against
radagon the bright white light we see as
well reminds me of the same light when
we enter inside the earth tree now I
don't think we physically came from here
but our spirit was inside the your tree
after we died and was returned to our
body when the greater will needed us to
return so that we could now fix the
shattered Elden ring sort of like with
the spirit summons whose Souls said by
Ronnie have not returned to the archery
I was entrusted this for thee
tolerance former master
bath calling forth spirits
summon them with it from Ash and
returned to the Earth tree the tarnished
at this point in the timeline within the
lands between seem like an afterthought
to those already living here the world
has lost hope for the tarnish to succeed
and instead of continuing that hope
those who have something to gain take
advantage of us manipulate our journey
to fit their own needs in a way the
guidance of Grace is doing the same to
us using us to fix what its own vessel
destroyed the entire world seems to know
what they can do with us labeling us as
soon as they lay their eyes on us you're
a tarnished
I can see it and I can also see
that you're not after my throat but all
of our own Journeys are different
through the lands between and based on
our own individual personalities we will
be swayed to believe inside with those
who influence us on our own path and I
think Ronnie asked it best at the very
start of our journey on when this
never-ending cycle of tarnish failures
will finally end
forgive mine intrusion tarnished I doubt
we shall again meet
but all the same
learn while the lands between how long
will it be I wonder before the tarnished
Tire of a basins to the two fingers
[Music]